Peter this really is fascinating to me
he'll be a free agent
he can go wherever he wants he can do
whatever he wants Bill Belichick has no
control over the situation at all what
do you think is gonna happen with Tom
Brady in 2020 my gut feeling but it's
only a gut feeling is that he's probably
gonna play somewhere else just you know
Mike look at what has to happen for him
to stay in New England in my opinion I
think first of all the money has to be
right for Brady second of all they've
got to make some major expenditures on
offense because why would you bring back
Tom Brady to muddle through the you know
the an offensive season like he just
muddled through you know they they
struggled to do anything the last seven
eight weeks of this season and a lot of
people are gonna say well Brady's
showing his age this is the worst
collection of offensive talent around
him probably in his career in New
England Mike and they didn't have a
tight end they lost on Gronkowski and
Jared Cook on the same day in March they
lost on their wide receivers in the
offseason Edelman was never really
Edelman he caught a hundred balls but it
just he didn't seem great all year
either
and he was really the only weapon that
that Brady had that plus the fact that
Belichick missed on end keel Harry you
might turn out to be a fine player but
in bypassing Deebo Samuel and and AJ
Brown and DK Metcalf and Terry Maclaurin
I mean was a major major mistake that
would have made a huge difference in the
Patriots season so I just think that if
you're Tom Brady you're looking at this
situation and say as painful as it is
I'd probably rather play somewhere else
where I have a chance for the next year
or two
and another spot where Bill Belichick
who we praise is the greatest coach of
all time in any sport failed locking
onto Mohamed Sanu and giving up a second
round pick to the Falcons when Emmanuel
Sanders Wayne who was obtained for a
third rounder by the 49ers and the 49ers
originally wanted Sinuhe Sanders ended
up being the much better option and I
don't know how much of it is the
complexity of the offense young
receivers having a hard time making an
impact right away maybe any of the guys
you mentioned who were very good
elsewhere would have struggled in New
England as well but you're right Peter
the cupboard is bare they're offensively
and if you're Tom Brady and you have
suitors lined up out the door and I
think they will be for business reasons
and for football reasons because he's
gonna sell tickets he's gonna sell
jerseys he is going to create excitement
you're not gonna win all your games
maybe you'll make it to the playoffs
maybe you won't but you're trying to
make money and Tom Brady is gonna help
you make a ton of money I think it's
gonna be like Peyton Manning in 2012 all
over again
and even though Tom Brady isn't
motivated by making top dollar top
dollar is going to be thrown at him I
believe by multiple different teams now
from your perspective is it the talent
around him that would be a big factor do
you think he's looking to have more of a
voice in how the offense is structured
in what his role is in who the talent
around him may be I mean the guy's been
doing it for 20 years
I assume he's learned a thing or two
about how to run a football team do you
think he wants to kind of be like Peyton
Manning was in Denver where it felt like
he had more control of the show then a
normal quarterback does yeah first of
all I don't think there will be teams
lining up out the door like they were
for Manning because I think people
looked at Manning once they knew he got
a clean bill of health after his neck
surgery as a three or four year player
which is what he turned out to be and I
don't think people would look at Brady
like that I think it'd probably be two
years and maybe even one but be that as
it may Mike I don't think he wants to go
somewhere to a brand new offense where
everything is absolutely brand new but
again I also don't think he wants to be
Peyton Manning
staying up all night with Adam GaSe and
and exchanging voice text to our voice
memos to to say hey remember this let's
do this
III mean I think Brady likes being
coached but the one other thing I think
we have to remember about this whole
thing Mike is that we have to remember
that Bill Belichick a quarter century
ago bench Bernie Kosar people in
Cleveland wanted to lynch him in 2001
when Drew Bledsoe was healthy and a lot
of people in the organization thought
that Bledsoe who at the time was the
highest paid player in football should
get his job back and Belichick stuck
with Brady he's not gonna be afraid to
make the tough decision charlie weis
told me yesterday it's gonna be on my
podcast this week that he'll treat Brady
the same way as he'll treat Devin
McCourty he used both of both of them as
incredibly valuable pieces on their team
but he's not gonna be emotional about it
he's gonna do what he feels is best for
the long-term interests of the team and
that's where you could have a potential
conflict between head coach and
ownership the crafts view yeah Tom Brady
is an unofficial member of the family
and if Brady wants to stay and they want
him to stay in Belichick wants him to go
you get into a little
rock-paper-scissors battle that could
get very interesting and you talked to
Robert Kraft and it sounds like he he
would he would like Brady to stay or
retire obviously he doesn't want to see
Tom Brady playing for someone else no
owner wants to see a star player go
somewhere else and play well they'd
rather see him play for no-one if
they're not going to play for the team
that they've spent their career with I
think that that's a very good way to put
it when I look back over all the stuff
that Kraft told me Saturday night before
the game that was easily the thing that
stood out the most basically I would
really I hope and pray that Tom plays
for us next year or number two that he
retires and that's not what Tom Brady
wants I can tell you that much
he might play for the Patriots and if he
does he'll go back willingly and I think
happily but
definitely I mean unless nobody wants
him unless there's not anyone of the 32
teams that want him he's not retiring
he's made it very clear to me that he's
playing next year so we'll see what
happens but again Mike I just think just
my gut feeling if I had to guess right
now I think he's gonna play somewhere
else in 2020 we need to have a friendly
over/under wager on the number of teams
that are actively courting Tom Brady if
he decides to open up his availability
for offers I think I'll say three I'll
take the over I say more than three okay
all right we have to we have to we have
to define what actively means has him in
for a visit and talks to him and all
that that would be active but has a
phone call that's not active how about
offers offers to bring him in for a
visit because he may not go he may say
no thank you but I think oh you know
actively pursue him from the standpoint
of wanting her to come visit all right
you stick with three if they go higher
if you want all right
well see how it plays out no I'll just
stick with I'll stick with three Joe
judge is gone the special teams
coordinator and he also had the
additional duty of receivers coach this
year based upon how the receivers played
I don't know I'd put that on my resume
josh mcdaniels is going to be gone as
offensive coordinator possibly you know
you're looking at major major changes in
New England but Bill Belichick is still
there right there's this the sense the
Sun is setting on the Patriots Bill
Belichick is still there
Peter I feel like this is gonna
rejuvenate him and excite him and and
compel him to prove that he has a lot to
do with why the team's been so
successful totally agree Mike the
Patriots are not gonna die they're not
gonna die but I will just say this since
Halloween the Miami after Halloween the
Miami Dolphins were five and four this
year in the Patriots were four and five
and that's with Tom Brady and Josh
McDaniels so who knows what happens who
knows maybe their quarterback opening
day next year is Andy Dalton don't laugh
it might be or Jared Stidham or somebody
who they draft but I do think that
Belichick is gonna play this year and
have a tremendous amount of fun remember
he's got his son Steve on his staff who
you know there's all sorts of
expectation out there that it that one
day Steve Belichick you know he hopes is
going to be coordinator maybe rising
above that to a head coach level so
there's a lot for Bill Belichick to
prove at least to himself in the coming
few years Peter I got a few names to
read off to you here as we consider what
the Patriots may do if Tom Brady leaves
Ryan Tannehill Marcus Mariota Philip
Rivers Eli Manning Case Keenum dak
Prescott Drew Brees
Teddy Bridgewater Jameis Winston Blake
bortles they're all due to become
unrestricted free agents now Prescott's
not going to be available but those are
the guys the starting quarterbacks with
name recognition or former starting
quarterbacks in the case of a guy like
bortles and Bridgewater who will be
available free and clear for Bill
Belichick to bring in if he wants to
and you mentioned Daulton he's in that
cut of guys who are under contract for
next year but are likely going to be
available because they're either going
to be released or they're available in
trade Cam Newton's out there Cam
Newton's two-and-oh against the New
England Patriots wouldn't that be
something to see Cam Newton in the New
England Patriot uniform I mean there's a
bunch of different ways Bill Belichick
can go which I think adds to this sense
of excitement
it's renewed it's rejuvenated it's
refreshed it's a reset button right for
Bill Belichick as he goes forward as you
said with Steve Belichick as his active
Protege possibly with the plan of
handing the baton to Steve at the
appropriate time two years five years
seven years ten years from now and Mike
I think the other thing that's really
interesting all those quarterbacks you
named you know
mino' idea neither do you who Bill
Belichick sits in his office feet up on
the desk watching tape of who he says I
really like that guy whether or not the
rest of the league likes them or not one
of the guys I think and I know these
people are gonna laugh at this I
think Bill Belichick would really like
to work with Andy Dalton
you know because Andy Dalton is he's a
football player you know and and he's
not he's not Tom Brady he's not gonna go
down in the pantheon I get it
no guys who gonna who are gonna go down
in the pantheon it aged 32 are not
available okay but Russell Wilson's not
available but I think Andy Dalton would
be a very compelling guy to be a bridge
either to be their quarterback for a
while or to be their bridge guide to the
next to the next quarterback or to take
Jared Stidham under his wing as brady
did some this year and make the best of
jared Stidham for 2021 and beyond
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports